ANA RITA PIRES: Hi there.
Welcome to recitation.
In lecture, you've been
learning about vector
spaces whose vectors are
actually matrices or functions,
and this is what our
problem today is about.
We have a set of 2 by 3
matrices whose null space
contains the vector [2, 1, 1].
And I want you to show
that this set is actually
a vector subspace of the
space of all 2 by 3 matrices.
And then, I want you
to find a basis for it.
When you're done, here is
an additional question.
What about the set of those 2
by 3 matrices whose column space
contains the vector [2, 1]?
All right.
Hit pause and work
on it yourself,
and when you're ready, I'll come
back and show you how I did it.
Hi.
I hope you managed to solve it.
Let's do it.
So, how do we show that
something is a vector subspace?
Well, there are only two
things that we need to check.
One is that if two vectors,
in this case two matrices,
are in that space, then
their sum is in that space.
And if you take a vector,
in this case a matrix,
and you multiply by a scalar
you'll still be in the space.
So, suppose that the matrices
A and B are in this set
that we want to
prove is a subspace.
So that means that A
times the vector [2, 1, 1]
is equal to the vector [0, 0].
Notice that the dimensions
are right: A is 2 by 3,
so this 3 by 1.
I should get a 2 by 1.
Suppose that [2, 1, 1] is
in the null space of A,
and that [2, 1, 1] is also in
the null space of B. Then what
is A plus B times [2, 1, 1]?
Is [2, 1, 1] in the
null space of A plus B?
Well, if you think
about what this means,
you're just adding
entry by entry.
And you can do it
slowly on your own
and just check that
this is what happens.
But by now you are familiar
enough with matrices
that this should
not be a surprise.
Well, this is [0, 0],
and this is [0, 0],
so their sum is [0, 0].
So, indeed, [2, 1, 1] is in
the null space of A plus B.
So if A and B are in the set, A
plus B is in the set, as well.
Let's check the other thing.
The other thing is A times
[2,  1, 1] is [0, 0].
So A is in the set,
because [2,  1, 1]
is in the null space of A. And
also, let's let c be a scalar.
That just means
that c is a number.
Then we want to
check that [2, 1,
1] is in the null space
of the matrix c*A.
That matrix is just the
matrix A except every entry is
multiplied by the number c.
Well, again, this is
how matrices work.
You can just pull
out the constant
and do A times [2, 1, 1] first.
Now this is the vector [0, 0].
So, this will simply be c
times [0, 0], which is [0, 0].
So the matrix c*A is also
contained in this set.
So the set is closed
under addition
and under multiplication
by scalar,
so the set is, indeed,
a vector subspace.
Well that takes care of the
first part of the question.
The second part was: find
a basis for the subspace.
So let's work on that now.
So the condition for a
matrix to be in this subspace
is that the vector [2, 1, 1]
is in the null space.
So I must have A times
[2, 1, 1] is equal to [0, 0].
So what is happening?
Well A is a 2 by 3 matrix.
So you can actually think
about what happens in each row
separately.
You'll have the first row of A
times [2, 1, 1] is equal to 0.
And the second row of A times
[2, 1, 1] is equal to 0.
So let's see what that means.
Each row of the matrix A in this
vector subspace must be [a, b,
c] [2; 1; 1] equal to 0.
This is not really a good
sentence, but you understand.
Which means that--
well let's see-- 2a
plus b plus c is equal to 0.
So I can actually write
it in this format.
It must be of the
form a, b, and then
c must be equal to -2a minus b.
Right?
So, furthermore, we
can say that it-- well,
one thing that you can do-- let
me write this here to help you.
It will be [a, 0, -2a]
plus [0, b, -bl.
See?
So what I'm doing is
I'm splitting this
into the linear
combination of two vectors.
I can pull out the
a out of this one,
and pull the b out
of this one, and it
must be a linear
combination-- that's
what this means, linear
combination-- of the following:
[1, 0, -2] and [0, 1, -1].
Does that make sense?
So this is what each
row of a must satisfy.
So we can now put
everything together
into what a basis for the
vector space has to be.
The basis will be, well
it's 2 by 3 matrix,
and each row must be a linear
combination of these two
vectors.
So let's write that-- 1, 0, -2.
I'll keep the second row
with zeros-- 0, 1, -1,
and I'll keep the
second row of zeros.
And now the same, but keeping
the first row with zeros,
I'm taking these vectors
on the second row.
So this is a basis
for my vector space.
One, two, three,
four; that also means
that the dimension
of the subspace is 4.
There was one further
question, which
was what can you say about
the set of those matrices that
contain the vector [2, 1]
in their column space?
What about the set of those 2
by 3 matrices whose column space
contains the vector [2, 1].
Is that a vector subspace?
Well one quick check
that you can always do
is check that the zero vector,
in this case the zero matrix,
belongs to the set.
Does the zero 2 by 3
matrix-- [0, 0, 0; 0, 0, 0].
Does this matrix
belong to this set?
Does this matrix contain
the vector [2, 1]
in its column space?
It does not, so this set
cannot be a vector subspace.
If you want to think about how
this 0 belonging in the set
has anything to do with the
two conditions being closed
under sum and closed under
multiplication by scalar,
simply think that
you should always
be able to multiply a
matrix by the scalar 0
and have it still be in the set.
That will be your zero matrix.
Well the zero matrix
is not in the set,
so the set is not
a vector subspace.
All right?
We're done.
Thank you.